hey what's up my name's samuel leeds i'm
a property investor and in this week's
video i'm going to be answering your
property investment questions so
anything that you need to know or just
want to know maybe you're curious about
property investment comment below in the
question box or in the comment section
and i will do my very best to answer
your question to help you become more
educated or inspired informed and
ultimately to help you in your property
journey to become financially
independent meaning that you don't need
to have a job because you've got a
passive income which is what property
gives you you own properties you rent
them out
that then pays for your life and then
you don't have to have a job that is
what being a property investor as a
profession is so if you want to do that
then presumably there's things you need
to know about property so comment them
below and i'll do my best to help also
if you appreciate my channel please do
me a massive favor and hit the like
button when you hit the like button it
means more people get to see the channel
which means that more people can be
educated inspired and also like you will
be able to become a property investor so
hit the like button subscribe as well
subscribe to the channel turn the
notification bell on and get commenting
below all right let's see what we had
from last week so
a guy called kazim kasim shakir said
hi samuel
hi kazim i'm in a privileged position to
own three properties two i own outright
i live in one of them and rent the other
and one i have a buy to let mortgage on
your videos have definitely played a
part in helping me my question is what
do you suggest is the next step i take i
want to build up my portfolio but i'm
torn between keeping the two i have
outright mortgage free or using the one
i rent out to raise cash for more any
advice would be greatly appreciated
great stuff well firstly kazim i want to
say congratulations on owning your three
properties and i don't know if you said
you're i don't know if you're a
full-time property investor or if you're
still working but my suggestion to you
and i don't know all the ins and outs of
your situation and what it is that
you're doing for work and what the
properties you are how much equity
you've got in them but you've got three
properties so my suggestion would be to
stop building your portfolio so to try
and find a fourth property now to buy a
fourth property
you unless you happen to have lots of
savings
then you're gonna need to take some
equity out of one of your prop one of
your existing properties take some
equity out i.e remortgage
maybe one of the properties that you own
outright or whatever and then use that
money to buy another property and the
plan is to slowly
build your property portfolio so i think
you're in a really good position and i'd
find something that's going to give you
as much cash flow as possible because
i mean
again i don't know your situation but
everybody has a financial freedom figure
so a financial freedom figure means how
much money do you need to be earning
every month in passive income
to be financially free to not have to
worry about money anymore if that
figures three thousand pounds four
thousand pounds you need to have a
portfolio of properties that gives you
that amount of income
most people worry about being debt free
so most people worry about
paying off their debts but rather than
worrying about being debt-free debt
isn't a bad thing
because debt can is is money
as long as it's good debt
it's leveraged money so instead of
worrying about being debt free you need
to think about being financially free so
i hope that helps you're a good position
there my friend all right next abdul
azlam
when you remortgage a property
does the lender do a credit check like
they do when applying for a traditional
buy to let mortgage
would remortgaging affect your credit
rating in a negative way thanks abdul
so if you're remortgaging it's very very
very similar to getting a mortgage in
the first place so
yes they are going to check your credit
and they are going to is going to be a
little bit of a process you're going to
have to fill out forms they're going to
check how much you're earning or they're
gonna have to check you know how the
property is doing they'll come out and
they'll revalue the property um ready
for the refinance so it's very very
similar to just getting a mortgage when
you buy a property at the beginning
in terms of does it affect your credit
rating in a negative way um
well it shouldn't do no
getting a mortgage on a property or
refinancing um it's not going to
negatively affect your credit it is
going to be down on your credit showing
that you have a mortgage but i mean my
credit rating is very very good it's
excellent and i have
a lot of mortgages um but my suggestion
would probably be to speak to a mortgage
broker and um maybe because this
getting a mortgage is different for
everybody and it depends on the type of
mortgage but i wouldn't worry about it
affecting your credit rating negatively
as long as you're paying back the
interest
and you're not going to pay back the
interest
your tenants are going to pay the
interest and you're going to have money
left over which will be yours for your
earnings because that's assuming that
you buy the right property
dan sanj says hi samuel i'm going to be
made redundant next month
sorry to hear that maybe it's a blessing
in disguise
i'm earning enough income
through my buy to let properties
awesome
so i don't plan on ever
returning to employed work well done dan
that's awesome however my buy select
mortgages are fixed rates and will all
need remortgaging in two years time the
properties are owned in my own name and
not through a limited company these buy
selling mortgages were given to me based
on my employment income
if i have no job will i still be able to
get a mortgage a decent rate when it
comes to remortgaging without my
employment income so okay first thing i
want to say as a disclaimer is i am not
a mortgage advisor okay so i can only
speak from my experience but dan i don't
think you'll have to remortgage in two
years
i think you may have misunderstood if
you've got a fixed rate of two years
after two years what will happen is
usually you will just
automatically go on to a variable rate
so if you've got a fixed rate of say
three percent for the next two years
in two years time you can refinance and
get a new mortgage or you can just go on
to the variable rate and it might be 2.5
or 3.5 or 40 depends on what interest
rates are doing at that time
so i wouldn't worry about it also
you can get
a refinance without having a job because
if they buy to let properties as long as
they're renting out nicely a lender
should be pretty comfortable lending
even if you've not got a full-time job
so i definitely wouldn't worry also
you've got two years to become a
millionaire right
so who knows where you'll be in two
years but
check with your lender but i think
you'll find and you can maybe comment
back down and tell me if i was right but
i think you'll find that after two years
you don't need to refinance it will just
they'll switch on automatically to a
variable interest rate you're awesome
but hey by the way if you're listening
to this and you're enjoying this video
don't forget hit the like button also
put your questions in the comment box
below as well charles royal
if i have ten thousand pounds spare how
should i spend it
first thing is don't spend it you
shouldn't spend it you should invest it
how should you invest it i would
probably recommend um putting some of it
towards a property business okay 10
girls are not going to get you very far
in the investment world but it will in
the property business world i.e put it
into a rent to rent business put it into
a deal sourcing business i'd put some of
it into your education i'd read books
attend seminars and then i'd put i'd
keep some of it in the bank um
ready for your first deal so
but i don't know your situation so what
would you do if that's the question but
i definitely want to spend it all right
league off says hi samuel i hope you're
in the family well just a quick note to
say nick hill ripple the 16 year old my
son rocco was so inspired with watching
your videos he desperately wanted to get
into property
his challenge was to own a property
while he was 16.
this isn't just him
he set up his company rocco goth
investments limited
brought to cheap property at auction
and had a private investor fund it
so yes
you can get into property at 16.
remember you don't know how close you
are to success if you give up wow what a
story and what a great dad
jumping on my youtube channel to tell
the story of your son rocco and how he's
bought his first property at 16
from an auction found a private investor
to fund it absolutely amazing absolutely
amazing and hey this is this is why i do
what i do to see people you know going
out doing deals 16. hey kids
if you're 16 if that doesn't inspire you
i don't know what does you can do it you
just need to take action get the
education and pull people in that will
support you and believe in you amazing
all right last question christopher
hubbard says when can we win a house off
you
listen man you don't need to win a house
off me um
i literally went down the streets of
london trying to give away free houses
and no one would take it because they
thought it was too good to be true and
they assumed i was just joking
it's not about waiting for someone to
give you a big break it's about making a
big break yourself
i don't really give people free houses
what i give is i give free education so
that they can go and invest in
properties using little or none of their
own money
so
my gift to you is education
you got to create your own break and go
make your own luck if you enjoyed this
video hit the like button don't forget
to comment your questions in the
question box below thanks so much for
watching i'll see you next time god
bless